This episode is sponsored
by curiosity stream,
their subscription streaming service
that offers over 2000 documentaries and
nonfiction titles from some of the world's
best film makers. The first 30 days.
I'll completely free if you sign
up@curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics and use the
Promo Code biographics.
You might never have heard of
German chemist Fritz harbor,
but there is a 50% chance that you
owe your very existence to this man's
invention.
The process he designed to confess
atmospheric nitrogen into ammonia made it
possible to produce
fertilizers on a large scale,
ensuring much more plentiful harvests
than ever before in the history of mankind
and therefore saving billions
of people from starvation.
It is estimate is that the food base of
half the current world's population is
based on his harbor Bosh process.
This achievement granted Dr Harbor,
the highest of accolades,
the Nobel prize for chemistry in 1918
and yet there is a dark side to this
benefactor of humanity, a story of
family abuse, of suicide, of blinds,
loyalty taken to the extreme and it's
the first ever use of weapons of mass
destruction on a battlefield.
This is the story of how Fritz Harbor,
the Jewish scientist,
unwittingly created the ultimate weapon
that brought about the Holocaust.
The story of Fritz Haber has been
described as worthy of a Greek tragic hero
free training from it's very first year
as all of the ingredients of a classic
tragedy,
father and son relationship conflicts
of the early shadow of death and Hubris.
And then of course there's the explosives.
Fritz Alba was born on December the
ninth 1868 in breast law pressure.
Now, Rod Slava in Poland, his
parents seek freedom. Paula,
we're both members of a wealthy Jewish
family established in the area since the
early 18 hundreds to be more precise.
They were members of the same family.
They were in fact first cousins who
would married against the will of their
relatives. His life had barely started
when it was already struck by tragedy.
His mother died from complications.
They need three weeks off to trial
to bath his father. So he agreed.
He was devastated leaving Fritz in the
camera of relatives. As a consequence,
the two group cold and
distance and then relationship.
It never really recovered
when his son was six,
Siegfried remarried and
had three daughters, Elsie,
Helen and Frieda with him.
Fritz actually got along with well,
but the life of Fritz.
It was to be shaped by his own ambitions
rather than the influence of his
family.
He had the ambition to Mazda Science from
an early age and the ambition to prove
that he was first a German and then a
Jew he was ready to serve is Kaiser and
his recently unified fatherland.
After completing high school in 1886
fritz declines and offered to become an
apprentice at his father's dying company.
The two men,
they frequently clashed and simply
could not work together. Instead,
Fritz applied to study
chemistry in Berlin.
I think his doctorate [inaudible] 1891
having achieved a doctorate in less than
five years was already impressive enough.
Moreover,
Fritz had to interrupt his studies for
one year of compulsory military service
and an artillery regimens.
This was to be his first experience with
the explosive power of modern warfare.
Hmm.
Siegfried Haba made another attempt to
to involve his son Fritz in the family
business, but their personalities, they
just weren't compatible. Fritz source.
Instead,
it's an outlet for his
ambition in academia starting
as an independent assistant
at the University of unit from 1892 to
[inaudible] 94 it was a unit that he
decided to convert from
Judaism to Lutheranism,
how belong to one of the first generations
of Jewish citizens to hit the labor
market after the unification of Germany.
He experienced a variety of options and
opportunities that were not available to
that predessessors and he had
young Jewish men like Fritz.
They still felt the need to convert in
order to progress in their careers and
prove that they were truly German Patriots
Arbors Korea. It indeed flourished.
In 1894 he moved to the University of
calls or up published two chemistry
treaties and escalated through the ranks
becoming professor at the age of just
it was at the University of calls row
between 1894 and 1911 that Fritz harbor
invented and developed what became
known as the Harbor Bosh process.
Let me explain this step by step.
They use of nitrogen based fertilizers
to increase production of agricultural
crops had already been in use for decades.
These fertilizers way expensive as they
relying on imports of sodium nitrate
from South American countries,
mostly Chile and so where exactly
do you find sodium nitrates?
Well that would be in Guano or
in other words, bird crap. Yup,
that's right.
The economy of entire countries
depended on bird crap and yes,
wars were fought over it and yet nitrogen,
well,
nitrogen is one of the most common
elements in the atmosphere. Indeed,
it makes up 80% of the air we breathe.
The genius of harbors invention,
Wistia fixate nitrogen to hydrogen
under extreme conditions of pressure.
This resulted in ammonia,
which would then become the
main ingredients for cheap
and efficient fertilizers,
which we still use today.
The consequences of this invention,
they've changed the world as we know it.
Before the Harbor Bosch Process,
the world's population had plateaued,
is about a billion people and this was
due to the inability to produce enough
food for everybody, but
the new fertilizers they
were going to change that.
Fritz all of his process,
the growth and sustainability
of the world's population
is such that it has been
estimated that the food base of about
half the world's current population
derives from the Harbor Bosh process.
This invention,
it was hailed as a miracle and it was
described by his contemporaries as brought
or stir loft or bread from the APP.
Okay.
Three years went by and harbors endeavors.
They were about to change as Germany and
the whole of Europe rush towards war in
the autumn of 1914 harbor enthusiastically
volunteered to put his signs in the
service of the Ministry of war and he had
the right experience at the right time.
Often Germany had invaded Belgium in
August causing the British Empire to
declare war.
The Royal Navy had launched a blockade
on gem and Portstewart slowly choke the
Kaisers war industry explosives,
just like fertilizers.
They relied on heavy quantities
of nitrogen to be produced,
which of course at that time still
required massive amounts of bird crap from
Chile, but with the British
blockade, the explosive factories,
they soon ran out of supplies as
a result of the gem in itinerary.
Could have been left without ammunition
off to 86 months of war. This,
this is where Fritz Hover and
enters the picture during peacetime,
he said a scientist to
belongs to the world,
but during wartime he
belongs to his country.
His first achievement was to adapt to
the Hama Bosch process to the production
of explosives, many of which
and nitrogen based compounds.
It's fascinating how this elements can be
used to both raise crops and also cool.
It's such destruction,
but Fritz Saba now left tenant Taba.
He had higher ambitions.
He gets approved again that he was a
true gentleman and a tree patriots.
He approached the high
commands with a new proposal.
This proposal was the weaponization
of chemicals to break the stalemate of
trench warfare on the western front.
Thursday the 22nd of April,
1915 British and Canadian troops
are entrenched in that position,
is facing the German lines on the heat
press salient in western Belgium all
appears quiet.
The allied observers for most of the day
until that is exactly 5:00 PM a gentle
Westwood breeze.
Dawn's blooming in that direction,
but today's wind is
carrying a strange missed,
which seems to build up and
thicken yod off the yard.
Some soldiers notice how birds caught
in the cloud and Midaz simply stop
flapping their wings and drop like
stones to the ground. The clouds.
Now a rolling toxic wall of intangible
death causes even the leaves and they ads
of grass to shrivel and die.
On This Day, the 22nd of April,
1915 at 5:00 PM the gentleman imperial
army launched a surprise attack against
the allied trenches,
the secret weapon 5,700 cylinders
containing 150 tons of chlorine gas.
The mastermind behind the
attack left tenant, Fritz Haba.
He had come to the front stoop personally
supervise the opening of the valves
that would unleash the first successful
use of a weapon of mass destruction on
the battlefields and British soldier left
and accounts of what happens when the
cloud of Corrine reached the
allied positions. It reads,
the living wall of green fog
about four feet in height,
moved towards the French line and spread
out to a width of about 180 meters.
As the wall of smoke grew higher,
the whole area disappeared into it.
Suddenly the rifle far from the
French but gradually die down.
Soon. We have strange shouts
coming from the green fog.
The cries became weaker
as morning coherence.
Then masses of soldiers tumbled upon
us from out of the fog ans collapsed.
Most weren't wounded to. They had
expressions of terror on their faces.
The effects of chlorine gas on
the body that just plain nasty.
The gas cools is acute
inflammation of the eyes, nose,
throat and lungs to which
the body's immune system
reacts with an overproduction
of Mucus seemingly always cog off and
you don't have to gasping for breath.
That wouldn't have a com.
It's like drowning on dry lands was Fritz
Saba and any way concerned about the
ethics of chemical warfare, but
apparently not as he was quoted as saying,
death is death no matter
how it is inflicted.
Although the battle ended in a stalemate.
Typical of the Western Front
hobbits contribution ends,
initial gas attack was
considered a complete success
and he was rewarded with a
promotion to captain and some
days of leave away from the front,
but it was he away from the pain and the
misery and the death. We're not ready,
but before I get into hobbies life,
I do want to mention a quick word
from our sponsor for this episode.
Curiosity stream.
Curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles from
some of the world's best film makers,
including exclusive originals.
You can get unlimited access starting
at just $2 and 99 cents a month,
and for our audience,
the first 30 days of completely free,
if you sign up@curiositystream.com forward
slash biographics and use the Promo
Code biographics all one word,
lower case.
If you're looking for a specific
recommendation from me on that platform,
I would recommend the history of food,
which talks a lot about the revolution
of agriculture and some about what we
talk about in this video or if you want
something a bit more well miserable as I
know you do because I know which
videos do well on this channel.
While you can watch
Hitler's miracle weapons.
Now all their docs are great watches
though and they're all available in that
free trial. It's available
in lots of platforms, Roku,
android x box one, smart TVs,
Ios, Chromecast, Amazon fire,
Kinzel and Apple TV and is also
available worldwide. Again,
get a curiosity stream.com forward slash
biographics for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries and
nonfiction series and for our listeners,
enter the Promo Code biographics when
prompted during the signup process and
your membership is completely
free for the first 30 days.
And let's get back to it
now.
This point,
we do need to stop for a moment and
rewinds and take a closer look at another
character in our story who
is often overlooked in life
and when almost forgotten
in death.
She is Fritz's wife cholera.
Cholera is life mirrored in many ways.
The life of the husbands.
She too was born into a Jewish family
from breast law and 1870 from parents who
were first cousins and
it's just like Fred Street,
then converted to Christianity at
the age of 27 but most significantly.
Clara was also a chemist
and a brilliant one at that.
Overcoming societal pressures and the
unfairness of a patriarchal society that
disapproved of women scientists,
Clara and enrolled in the breast law
university earning a doctorate Suma cum
laude in 1900 she became the first
German woman to be awarded a phd in
chemistry,
Flora and Fritz.
They met with the first time in 1898 it
dancing lesson and they fell in love and
then for proposed to
her shortly thereafter,
but unusually for that
time Clara had declines.
The offer is she first wanted to
establish her own financial and personal
independence. Fritz did not give
up and z continued as courtship,
which culminated in their marriage
in 1901 their only son, Herman.
He was born the following year according
to one of harbors, biographers,
Diedrich Stoltz and bag.
That union was a happy and successful one.
Fritz was deeply in love with Clarins.
Okay.
Every occasion to dote on her
as well as their child's not.
Everybody agreed with that.
Clara herself confided to her friends.
This a life group more miserable.
There's time went on as she put it.
The main reason for that was Fritz is
oppressive way of putting himself first in
our home and marriage so that are less
ruthlessly self assertive personality was
simply destroyed their marriage.
It's soon was in crisis.
Pardo was seldom at home and made his
disdain for his scientific endeavors quite
clear.
He runs on frequent trips with colleagues
and even had affairs with other women
and a letter to her old
mensa professor abig.
Clara had even complains that Fritz is
games and scientific successes had been
her loss.
The fact is that Clara Mfr was not suited
to the traditional subservient role
assigned to housewives. In the early
20th century. She was a feminist,
firmly believing that a woman's intellect
was by no means in Feria to a man
sinned. Yet even though she actively
contributed to her husband's research on
fertilizers or work at when's uncredited.
In later years,
she was confined to translating into
English. Fritz is scientific papers.
Clara was also a staunch pacifist
and since denounced from the outset,
the madness of the Great Wall when Fritz
started contributing to the war effort
by using his harbor Bosch
process to produce explosives,
she was appalled and open late.
The post is worked announcing it as a
perversion of the ideals of science and a
sign of barbarity corrupting
the very disciplined,
which ought to bring
new insights into life.
Then when our husband enthusiastically
dedicated himself to the application of
chemical warfare,
well,
this was the final straw to the fragile
balance of their marriage and do our own
psyche. According to Stolsenberg, she
had a family history of depression.
Kara herself may have
suffered from it too.
So she desperately pleaded with Fritz
to cease working with the military,
but instead of dealing
with our views and private,
his angry reaction was to denounce her
in public of making statements that were
treasonists to the fatherland.
All right,
so now let's get back to those fateful
days after the battle of eep prep.
Captain Fritz Hall that
is being celebrated by the
German Imperial Army High
Commands for his success with chlorine
and he's now a bounce and leave for
another mission on the eastern front.
This mission,
well it was the Russians turn to drown
on try then maybe you can tell what
happened exactly on May the second 1915
but we know at least some of the facts,
flora and Fritz have another argument
since they had been sparked by the role
that he played in eat Bruh or the news
that he was going to repeat his exploits
against the Russians.
That nice while he is sleeping,
Clara walks into their garden
carrying Fritz is service side.
Sidearm a Luger nine millimeter.
A single shot rings out Herman
Khara and Fritz is only child age.
Teen runs into the garden to find his
mother slowly dying from a self inflicted
pistol. Shot to the chest,
Clara dies and I'm in zombies.
And what did Captain Haba
do? Well, he just left.
He was due on the eastern front to
release more gas on Germany's enemies.
And so he left the very next morning
leaving common to grieve alone.
Clarissa named [inaudible]
in German means always true.
Perhaps it was her desire to stay always
true to how the leafs that led to her
taking in life as,
but Fritz,
why did he leave his son alone
in that terrible moments?
Was it his sense of extreme duty
and loyalty to the Fatherland?
Was it unwillingness to cope with the
responsibility of his wife suicide or
we'll never really know
for the rest of his life.
Harbor never discussed any of the details
of car his death on May the eighth
alone arbitrary in a newspaper,
report it on the suicide of the wife
of Dr h if the secret service who is
currently at the front adding that.
The reasons for the unhappy women's act.
I don't know how that remarried to as
data with Charlotte Nathan and had two
children.
Eva lutes,
Parlez first son never approved of
this union and the degree of feathering
feather apart from his father
and Disney family I'm in,
did not have a happy life.
He moved to the USA shortly before the
Algebraic of World War Two and in 1946 he
too committed suicide.
Is that in daughter Claire was a
chemist employed by the u s government's
research and antidote for chlorine gas.
When our research project was shut down
in favor of work on the atomic bomb,
she too for a third time in three
consecutive generations committed suicide.
Germany's defeat in November of 1918 was
a devastating blow for Captain Harbor
who is now professor Haba once again,
that yet however brought him a
much needed piece of good news.
His invention of the hub of Bosch
process was selected by the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences is winner for that.
He has Nobel prize in Chemistry.
The official motivation being for the
synthesis of ammonia from its elements.
Now it had been common for scientists
have both sides during the war to serve
and their respective countries, chemical
warfare units, future Nobel laureates,
James Franco stuff hubs to auto hunt,
served as gas strips and hobbyists units,
but probably the winds from the great
war that was still too fresh and Harb.
His prize was received as an
outrage by the scientific community,
especially in the u s and the UK
where he was considered a war.
Criminal Professor Ernst Rutherford,
father of nuclear physics
famously refused to shake.
Fritz Havas handed a conference in
Cambridge in 1919 despite international
isolation, Fritz Harbor, he
managed to keep himself busy first.
In 1919 he was appointed director of the
newly founded [inaudible] company and I
remember that name,
that it's a chemical
manufacturer specializing in
fertilizers and pesticides and
then came his next big project.
The same way he had managed to make bread
from Haba now devoted himself to turn
water into gold or to be more correct.
Do you want to do extract
gold from sea water?
This was his attempt to do support.
The recently established Weimar
republic by paying back Germany's war
reparations to the allied powers.
Unfortunately,
the concentration of golden seawater
turned out to be two skus and the process
to extract it was too costly.
Yeah.
Does life all his efforts to serve his
country as best he could to the German
people would soon prove
to be an ungrateful one.
Let's not forget that dark
forces where it works.
During the 1920s and early 1930s as
soon as the Nazis were voted into power,
a new law was ratified in April,
1933 which prevented Jews from holding
positions in the civil service.
For other than time,
he held the role of presidents of the
Kaysville Home Institute for physics and
Electric Chemistry. A smear
campaign was launched, you Al Stim,
although he is a convert
and to form a world war,
one decorated veteran was legally entitled
to keep us post. This did not apply.
However, to his collaborators, three
quarters of which we're still Jews,
and so he was simply audit to
fire them. In this case, hover,
applying a form of silent
resistance to Nazi prevarications,
delayed their dismissal until he could
find employment for each one of them,
but at Harvard had realized
that it was time to go.
Between the summer of 1933 and
30 1934 frets, his former wife,
Charlotte and all of his children from
both marriages all fled abroad and
settled in the UK. Habo is now
suffering from cardiovascular disease,
but when he was offered a directorship
at a research institute in British
Palestine, he eagerly accepted
halfway through his journey in Basel,
Switzerland for Tava succumb to a
fatal episode of acute heart failure.
It was the 29th of January,
1934 he was buried in the local cemetery
where his ashes were joined by as
remains three years later.
Yeah.
Now, it is uncommon for us to continue
our stories after the death of a main
character,
but what happened some years after
Fritz harbors demise is suddenly worth
telling. If you remember
back in 1919 Hubbard had been
one of the founders of the
[inaudible] Gash chemical company
dedicated to fertilizers and pesticides.
One of their top selling products to
which are the had personally contributed
was in fact a very powerful pesticide
for agricultural use and improvements on
the existing hydrogen
cyanide or prosec acid.
It was enriched with absorbance and an
Irish tends to act as a warning against
leaks.
It was used mainly for delousing purposes
until August of 1941 and ss cabs in
call each used it as a gassing
agent to kill some Russian pdws.
This came to the attention of Rudolph
[inaudible] of a Nazi officials.
They were looking for a solution to
solve what they considered the ultimate
problem. You would say that they
were looking for a final solution,
a cheap and efficient way to
exterminate millions of Jews,
Roemer and other undesirables.
The pesticide was modified
to remove its warning odor,
and it's I irritants so as to take
the victim's completely by surprise.
The original name of the chemical, well,
that was Zyklon. It's modified version.
The infamous is like plan B,
the preferred killing tool
used by the Nazi delirium too,
and the lives of millions of innocent
Jews and other prisoners in the gas
chambers of Auschwitz.
Malveaux sin and to book involved among
the countless dad with some of Fritz
harvest relatives. This was
the last defining act of
the tragedy of Fritz Haber,
a Jew who renounced his faith to prove
he was a worthy German and demand torn
apart by his ambition,
his devotion to the fatherland and his
inability to love those who were closest
to him.
Well, this is where we end.
Today's biographics. I hope
you enjoyed this episode.
Despite it's rather dark themes.
We love to hear about your
views on Fritz harbor,
should we remember him
as a genius scientist who
prevented countless famines and
truly deserving of a Nobel prize or as
a callus monster who contributed to the
disintegration of a heroine and to
the horrors of modern warfare? Well,
leave your comments below.
As usual,
we do love a good debate and if you
want more stories like this interesting,
controversial,
inspiring lives,
while please do click that
subscribe button below.
We put out new videos three times a week.
So spay yourself the hassle of
checking in and hit the bell icon.
Say you're the first to know
when we put out a new video.
If you want to learn
more about the Holocaust,
watch our previous
biographics episodes about,
off I come in the architects
of the final solution,
and why not check it off
video about Timothy Mcveigh,
and then you can see the tenuous link
between that American terrorist and our
protagonist of today.
Also a big thanks to curiosity stream
for sponsoring 30 days for free.
Click the link in the description below,
and as always, thank you for watching.